can democrats win in the fall by running
on maintaining and restoring abortion
rights we have an early signal that
suggests the answer at least in some
districts might be yes this is a super
interesting story
democrats just won a swind swing
district by focusing on abortion and
that should scare republicans writes
phillip elliott for time magazine this
is a very interesting situation
um
now an unexpected echo to yesterday's
column democrats may not be toast in the
house it's a long shot but there's a new
data point from tuesday evening that
makes it more plausible
sending republicans in washington into a
late night scramble how had they gotten
a new york special election so wrong
the seat representing new york's 19th
congressional district opened in may
when congressman delgado was appointed
lieutenant governor
obama twice won the hudson river valley
district before it pivoted to trump in
2016 and biden in 2020. it's a swing
district with more than 90 percent of
ballots reported democratic nominee pat
ryan was ahead with 52 percent of the
vote enough to send him to dc through
the balance of delgado's term
maybe everything isn't entirely terrible
for democrats
maybe question uh both parties nominated
mainstream candidates to fill delgado's
seat they invested in the race abortion
rights was the um a primary
uh topic for democrats and the economy
for republicans in an almost perfect
swing district the small turnout
election favored the democrat a county
executive from the establishment wing of
the party this comes on the heels of
kansas voters rejecting an amendment to
the kansas constitution uh that would
have made it easier to further restrict
access to abortion
this is very interesting because the
conventional wisdom is it's the economy
stupid if the perception is the
economy's good it's good for whoever is
in power if the perception is the
economy is bad it's good for whoever is
out of power now in a mixed
administration a mixed congress figuring
out well who's in can have different
interpretations but putting that aside
for a moment
typically
particularly for democrats when they run
on something like abortion or social
issues generally it's not particularly
good but we have a situation here in
this it's admittedly it's a special
election but it is like the perfect
swing district
the candidate who is a democrat running
on abortion rights
one
is this a sign
that maybe november won't be as bad for
democrats as some are predicting in the
house well it's a possibility
and we've seen it happen to some degree
in michigan
and at this point in time with what is
it about nine weeks until the midterm
elections incredibly
the economy is good and so you can walk
and chew gum at the same time the
messaging should be
look at how great the economy is
and also
these are dangerous infringements
on women's rights coming from the
republican party coming from the right
wing supreme court and we need to elect
some democrats in order to try to
reverse that and so the question becomes
was the overturning of roe v wade
potentially very bad for the republican
party we don't know the answer yet and
there are many prognosticators saying it
is bad or it's good or it doesn't matter
well ultimately these are just
predictions we won't know until we see
the results in november
the right has a playbook that they stick
to
and they are
confident that it will always work
and
the general population's views on a
number of different issues particularly
social issues but some economic issues
as well like should taxes be used on the
rich to help the general population the
country has moved to the left on
basically every single one of those
issues and in a just and reasonable
situation
you would think that at a certain point
that uh public belief those public
perceptions those public opinions would
be reflected in the way that the results
shake out now because of gerrymandering
and campaign finance and all these
different things voter suppression from
from republicans all the techniques that
we've talked about that they use it
hasn't happened to the degree that it
should have
maybe we will actually see that happen
in november so very good news
uh there out of that new york district
we're going to watch all districts
closely and we're going to watch the
polling in the house as we head into
november